for you guys what has it been like what
has your life been like since
yeah it was that was probably the worst
day of my life you know because before
when he was convicted i thought well
we're going to fight this we're going to
do this you know but he'll never
you know it it's like we'll see but i
will get them out you know and then when
we
that sent that day of sentencing i i was
just um
uh it's just the worst it was just like
i'd been told my son was dead or
something you know it was just horrible
and then i you know you got to just dust
yourself off and
i thought okay got to keep going i
cannot live with this i cannot live with
him
um rotting away
and essentially in a box i mean right
now he is um
he's been since covid on uh 22 to 24
hour lockdown
in an 8 by 10 metal box fed through a
slot in the door
no breaks now right now it's 24 hours
sometimes it used to
for a while it was 22 hours you know and
they got out for two hours
24 hours a day day after day in a metal
box
staring at a metal wall
because of covered you know this is
unacceptable
that this cannot so i might so basically
my life's been actually before
sentencing and after sentencing
um my main goal every day is the eye on
the prize of ross's freedom of seeing
him walk out of that place
and um going on to live his life and i
think make a contribution i mean ross
has a lot of very
great ideas he's quite intelligent
and he even recently wrote it's
published on medium.com
and he's written a lot of things that
are on medium as well as on our website
but just to show his intentions um i
don't know if you're aware of the
issue with what's app being private but
pedophiles and other
you know nefarious people hiding behind
that cover
and through artificial intelligence ross
has come up with a way that can
maintain privacy but still not allow
that kind of activity
don't ask me to explain it i tried to
read it i can't even understand it
but he did run it by um experts who said
it's got a lot of promise i think you're
on to something but he can't develop it
because he's in prison
so that's just an example of the kind of
thing he wants to do he's very um
philanthropic really and compassionate
and that's where he was coming from the
silk road
not saying he didn't make a mistake i'm
not saying that it was a bad idea
in a lot of ways i'm not defending it
i'm just saying his intentions as a 26
year old idealist
that's where he was coming from and he's
still idealistic and he still
cares about humanity and he's being
wasted he's just being wasted in there
so he's he's actually developed creating
new concepts for technology and for
these apps
and and still innovating from prison
essentially
essentially i mean and he doesn't can't
get on the internet
so i'm not sure exactly how he's
managing this but it's uh he's been
reading about ai
in artificial intelligence for a while
and i don't know he's just
and he's got other writings in there
about um bitcoin and about
and even some things personal things
like he is one that's
the five keys to inner strength i
learned in five years in prison
that are is quite inspirational um his
attitude is
amazing i'm i'm inspired to keep going
by him because he's so
uh he will not let himself be brought
down and become bitter or become
paralyzed by the situation he just won't
and many
of course understandably do and he just
he won't he just
he won't go down the negative track i
mean i've
been guilty myself of like you know i
just have a few words to say about the
judge say
to him and he's like nope we're not
going to go there
it's just she's part of the system it
doesn't matter she doesn't matter
it's all and i'm like yeah but blah blah
blah and he's like
nope we're not going to go we're not
going to let this
because what can happen of course is the
negativity
and the anger and the fear and all that
stuff can just drag you down
to the point where you're and he won't
he is very disciplined about that and it
helps me because i'm like yeah i can't i
gotta
control my thinking so i don't get
dragged down
because i'm no good to anybody if i do
what are your conversations like
with ross nowadays and how often do you
guys communicate
not well he can't call anymore because
he's on this 24 hour day lockdown
um so usually uh
and he's have very limited minutes you
can't talk very long
so they're usually fairly you know
superficial in a way because it's like
how are you are you feeling okay
what you eat you know it's like and um
you know he's like how are you
and you know it's like that and then
then it goes you are talking to a
federal
uh you have like you have like 10 or 15
minutes right that's it
well yeah but um he's saving his minutes
he's trying to
ration his minutes and so um yeah it's
um
so we don't usually talk a full 15 even
because
he wants to spread it out over the month
but now he has no
he can't call because he can't they
don't let him out of the cell because of
kobit
even though in his unit there is no case
of covid but
you know don't ask me about why the
prison does a lot of things
what what prison is he in he's a
the maximum security prison in tucson
arizona
maximum security yeah he's been in
maximum security prison
first he went to florence and the reason
he's a maximum
is because of his sentence because it's
an automatic life sentence you're in the
maximum
um his if you went by his uh
they take a score for your offense
levels in terms of your danger
even with his charges which are you know
violent
yeah uh he'd be in a camp when he came
to that first prison in florence
colorado which by the way is the step
down from the supermax
it's a huge prison complex it's their
it's a very gang-heavy violence-heavy
prison
that they threw them into um they said
what are you doing in here they're
looking at the paper going what are you
and then they go oh yeah the sentence
he was he'd be in a camp he'd be you
know based on his
you know score and um but
that's what they do they put you in
maximum so now he isn't a maximum but
he's in a safer place because the other
place
what happened was they have he was being
pressured
to within other guys but they were being
pressured to beat up
what they said was a snitch this guy and
this happens in there where they're like
you've got to do this
you know or else or else you or else you
know
and ross said look i'm not violent i'm
not going to beat up some guy i'm not
going to do it
i don't even know the guy i mean there's
no why would i you know
and so he resisted and put himself in
protective custody
which was solitary for like three months
and then
um thankfully was sent to
tucson which is one of three what they
call safe yards
in the system for people who would be a
targeted if they were led into the
regular
population which ross would be now
because he refused to do that
and um so it's it's safe i'm
you know it's still prison it's still
maximum security
but it's it doesn't have violent people
in there
and so it's it's not as much of a danger
you know it was a very dangerous place
he was in before
but now you're saying he's confined into
just a box by himself
basically no he actually has um
a uh he has um hang on one second
uh he has a um cell mate okay
i